life for justina odomozue is difficult
to navigate with chronic pain
the 61 year old was born with sickle
cell disease
she has lost a son as a result of it her
job as a nurse
and eventually her own organs
it destroyed my kidney and i now have
kidney failure
i have to put needle in my arm
you see how swollen it is
like justina 15 000 people in the uk
live with the condition
they may smile on the outside but their
crises mean they're often in
excruciating pain
let me tell you sickle cell pain there's
no other pain like it because of the
sickle i have a very high pain threshold
so my mom didn't believe i was i was in
labor because i wasn't screaming you
know
sickle cell disease is a complex genetic
blood disorder now after nearly three
decades
potentially life-changing treatment
a new drug known as krizan lizumab is
set to be rolled out to 5 000 people
over the next three years
it's delivered by a transfusion drip and
works by binding to a protein in the
blood cells to prevent the restriction
of blood and oxygen supply
this drug is going to bind to the
proteins and stop that clumping from
happening and really save people
excruciating pain and a better quality
of life you know um i i know people who
have died as a result of um you know
sickle cell crisis so it's not just
about organ damage it can actually be a
fatal condition and so this drug is
genuinely life-changing
this is the first treatment for the
condition in nearly three decades and
experts say it'll help thousands get a
better chance in life
anyone knowing anything about sickle
cell that we have restricted blood flow
and that's what caused the painful
crisis and at times can lead to limb
damage organ damage and and obviously
death so this no doubt will be a great
in terms of the aspects of taking things
forward
after a lifetime of goodbyes justina
hopes this can be the end of monthly
blood transfusions and the fear of
having a crisis
sadia chowdhury sky news in manchester